[Music]
thank you
welcome back to another episode of
WhatsApp Prof hello Walter what happened
there Martin
we wanted to get some water behind the
ears you should be sitting under the
shower
we'll wait under the ears
well
this is an interesting topic that you
are going to Enlighten us with
well you see Martin we got so many
questions and remember we spoke about uh
my story and how I changed from an
evolutionist to a creationist
and I've always told the story that I
wrote these questions on the board yes
and then somebody contacted me and said
he wants the questions
and I'm going he wants the questions
that's 36 years ago yeah what were the
questions I of course I have more or
less an idea what we spoke about that
created such a stir then
and uh
and then he said to me he's writing a
book and he wants to incorporate the 10
questions can I please send them to him
so it forced me to go and sit down and
think what was it exactly that we spoke
about that day
and I cannot guarantee that it's exactly
the same but it's more or less what we
spoke about mainly about the genetic
aspect more than the other aspects but
they did come up
so I think it's a pretty accurate
reflection of what transpired that day
well in any case
these 10 that you've got now
is still enough to debunk the whole well
I wouldn't say that we're going to
create uh you know tidal waves
but they will hopefully make people
think yeah that's that's what it's about
right I think it's important because you
know what
where does it start
if the creation
narrative is taken away why do you want
to why do you want to study the rest of
the Bible the rest is obsolete we
continually say that the Three Angels
messages
have to be proclaimed and one of the
first things in the first in the Three
Angels messages
is worship God who made exactly the
Creator so this is important so let's
ask them let's pray the Lord for a word
of Prayer our heavenly father
thank you that we can discuss
this beautiful creation of yours we ask
that you Enlighten our minds Enlighten
the words and everyone watching and
listening to this in Jesus name amen
and a Martin another thing that's
constantly popping up these days is we
have to follow the science yes
and what does the science say you know
and all these names and all of these
things come into mind when we have to
follow the science and so the churches
jump on the bandwagon and say we have to
follow the science that said even the
churches
so actually they put science above God
because sometimes God most of the times
God says something and science says the
other and sometimes they say you know we
rely on peer-reviewed journals
and the thought came to mind how many
thousands
literally thousands upon thousands of
Publications are there in peer-reviewed
journals on evolution
so if we want to follow the signs we
have to throw the Bible away
if it comes to that right
and even if it comes to other issues how
often has science proven to be exactly
the opposite of reality see that is the
science that the Bible calls calls
science so-called falsely so-called
falsely so called all right so we're
going to see if we can run through those
10 points
and it might take a while
maybe it doesn't take so long we'll see
we'll play it by ear
so we're going to talk about creation
and I guess everybody who looks at that
picture in the backdrop will realize
that that's one of Henry stauber's
pictures yeah and this it also is part
of the creation movie and the adventure
Prof that was aired yes but now it's in
a WhatsApp problem yes the different
setting so sorry Henry I'm just taking
your place for a while on this side
that's fine we're going to talk about
creation
so the Bible talks about the beginning
in the beginning and you know Martin
that is the Crux of the whole story
if that story in the Bible is wrong
then what is the point
of the cross
now there is no point then because
Evolution argues that
death was the means whereby we got
Improvement through natural selection
survival of the fittest to the detriment
of the unfit So eventually death was the
process that led to all the varieties
that we have today
and the Bible clearly says death is a
consequence of sin yes and sin can only
be committed by the moral creature that
comes at the end of the creation account
so you know what in the beginning like
you've just mentioned now you already
actually debunk it you're already debunk
it because
if there was no sin there wouldn't have
been any death
So Adam and Eve would have lived forever
forever so way can Evolution fit in then
and what about the cross why would Jesus
die to give eternal life
and to give life back
if it wasn't so in the beginning it it
makes no scientific sense it makes no
religious sense and that's why theistic
evolution is a misnomer oh it's it's a
compromise of irrelevance because it
negates the atonement completely
completely so it's if you want to think
of long periods of creation you better
be actually be an atheist there's no
yeah there's no
way you can fit God into that as well
well so in the beginning Martin the
Bible says the Lord created God created
the heavens the Earth
and everything that in them is
and he spoke and it stood fast
now is that a myth and therefore do we
have to put the religion into the realm
of Mythology as well that's where we
will head for if that is the case
Exodus chapter 20 verse 11.6 days the
Lord made Heaven and Earth the sea and
all that in them is and rested the
seventh day
this comes at the end of the fourth
Commandment
so the fourth Commandment is actually
pivotal
there's no other Commandment that
everything can hang on right so if faith
is the substance of things hoped for
the evidence of Things Not Seen I wasn't
there when it was made no I didn't see
it in fact Adam wasn't there when it was
made he only woke up and it was there
right yes
so faith is the substance of things
hoped for the evidence of Things Not
Seen and without faith it is impossible
to please him
and there it is
in the fourth Commandment
and you are told to honor that fourth
Commandment to have a relationship with
God to spend time with God because
that's what a relationship requires why
for in six days the Lord made Heaven and
Earth the sea and all that in them is
and rested on the seventh day period
can I
put in something here yes there is
nothing mentioned of a moon there
being naughty modern
but why do the Moon the Moon is there
but it's there on the fourth day on the
fourth day but in this one why Six Days
on the seventh I rested it didn't stay
there because on the seventh sixth day
the moon was rising or anything like
that no all right but uh let's keep that
for another topic I know you're a heart
under the color about that but the first
week
is a week that God put into place and is
the model for all subsequent weeks
that's it period it never changed since
creation correct and if the Sabbath
should ever have been lost
that there was a miracle in the
wilderness
for six days the manor fell
and on the seventh day there was none on
the sixth day it lasted twice by the way
that was also not subject to the Moon
because then it would have been a
frightening scenario you see that's what
I mean it's actually logical if you just
read correct and if it should ever have
been lost it was reiterated at the grave
because they rested according to the
Commandment on the Sabbath day and very
early in the first day of the week they
went and took spices and ointments to
anoint the body of Christ and he had
risen right
so the Julian calendar was in place then
already
that was changed to the Gregorian
calendar because lo and behold the
Caesars want to have their stamp on it
right and the current seesaw happened to
be the pope he wanted to have his stamp
on there so the Jesuits moved it by 10
days but they didn't change the cycle of
the week it's been the same from
creation till today so that's pivotal if
the Lord made the heavens and the earth
and the Sea and all that in them is and
rested on the seventh day if he really
did it in six days
then evolution is the counter argument
for this account
exactly so the opposer to God
brought in a narrative opposing the
creation this is part of the Great
controversy that's it and isn't it
interesting that the great controversy
regarding this issue started in 1844
because Charles Darwin wrote his first
draft from the Origin of Species in 1844
and sent it out for comment
so everything fits into this picture of
a great end time ideological battle Yeah
now Martin when I as an evolutionist was
confronted with this in six days story
can you imagine
my thoughts yeah well it's still the
same with anybody that still has that
same mindset I thought to myself the man
who told me this I said thought you
ignorant peasant what's wrong with you
exactly
that's a thing the world tells you that
if you believe actually the biblical
narrative you're actually stupid you're
actually stupid you're you're a fool
and I remember he brought me these books
they're all creation books and I read
them
and of course
I was used to tearing this stuff apart
with the students at the University
because we had those creationists come
and visit and we took pleasure in
ripping it apart and ridiculing what
they were saying
and eventually he got so frustrated with
me and he says I don't have a problem
with Evolution you have a problem you
solve it remember that yeah yeah
so the ball was basically in my court
the Sabbath was also in there and also
said yeah you saw that Alpha yourself I
also don't have a problem with the
server so how can you keep a Sabbath day
in recognition of millions of years of
evolution you might as well can it right
it's ridiculous exactly unless you work
it through now I'm not going to tell my
story because we've told it many times
though we're going to look at what
happened on that fateful day
when I for the first time
actually put some thoughts on the screen
with all those professors sitting there
all the post-grad students there in that
think tank that evolutionary Think Tank
discussion group class
and the result was pandemonium
anger such as you have never seen it's
as though a bunch of hornets had come
into the Hall
and it stung everyone it's a Pity there
weren't any cameras that could have
recorded this that would have been
interesting because one of my colleagues
literally was foaming at the mouth from
anger it was blood red
and they were swearing at me
now that really made a great impression
on me because what had I said I'd ask
questions yeah
at that stage I didn't even have the
answers
do you know what I mean it takes time it
takes years to study it through but I
just asked the questions
and pandemonium broke loose
so I thought to myself you know this is
deeper than we think there's something
else going on here it's worthy of study
exactly
Genesis chapter 6 verse 17 and behold I
even I to bring a flood of waters upon
the Earth To Destroy All Flesh wherein
there is Breath of Life from under the
heaven and everything that is in the
Earth shall
die now it's interesting if you read
that verse Martin everything that is in
the Earth shall die
now he called the dry land Earth
so everything on Earth
died
that doesn't mean everything in the
waters died no so many creatures in the
catastrophe did die even in the Marine
World of course
especially if you're going to pour the
marine environment over the land you're
going to have a lot of catastrophes
you're going to have a lot of death
but this verse
is a total contradiction of science
because science cannot afford a
universal destruction
because then you would have to start
Evolution all over again
yeah I understand yeah okay so if at
some stage all life was there
then a universal destruction destroyed
everything on land and only that which
was in a ship survive
you would have to start the evolutionary
process again if you didn't believe the
ship narrative right as a fairy tale
it's a great reset
should be working for the world economic
forum
so this is fascinating so everything
died
that sentence stands in absolute
opposition to peer-reviewed science
absolute opposition they will admit to
local flooding
local catastrophes but never to
Universal
so we're not going to go into all the
great details if people want to study
that they can look at the whole
creation series that we have we're going
to look at 10 questions and highlight
some interesting points to see where we
are going can they also read that book
that you wrote Genesis conflict yes it's
on on our downloads they can get it
there
so 10 points to ponder Martin
let's go through 10 points to ponder
number one
if the evolution of life started with
low diversity
and diversity increased over time why
does the fossil record show higher
diversity in the past and lower
diversity as time progressed
that's uh
right about way of saying everything
seems upside down of what it should be
like
now why would evolution of Life start
with low diversity well obviously Martin
If evolution is a fact and somewhere by
chance life evolved then it was only in
one little spot yes exactly and from
that over millions of years diversity
must have increased if the scenario even
holds water
so you must expect low diversity
becoming more and more and more and more
why must speaker more and more because
we have lots of things around today yeah
so from one little start to many
that should be reflected in the fossil
record because that's a theory or that
is what evolution tells you is supposed
to happen the exact opposite we find in
the fossil record
a massive diversity and a lower
diversity today yeah
that is the opposite of what you would
expect why is it so why is it so
and why is the diversity so much greater
in the past than it is today for example
one whole category of animals the
mammal-like reptiles yeah a huge
category of animals is gone
it's only in the fossil record
and that's very interesting now I don't
want to go into too much detail great
too much controversy
but if we take the vertebrates today
then you have the Marine vertebrates you
have the fishes you have then the first
land ones halfway in between they say
the amphibians then you have the
reptiles and then you have the mammals
nine times past there was another
category the mammal-like reptiles
they're gone
and then of course in each category
there was a huge diversity
that we don't have today
so it's been whittled down whittled down
whittled down so
question why does it show this reverse
sequence
the next question we have if evolution
of necessity should progress from small
creatures to large creatures over time
why does the fossil record show the
reverse
is that an interesting question of
course
all right now let's just explain that
there was a scientist and his name was
Carol
and he basically made a law the law of
Carol which states that Evolution always
progresses from small to large obviously
if you're going to have a chance
development of life in some little mud
pool it's going to be a unicellular
creature that's small yeah you don't
expect the mud pool to
produce an elephant exactly that's big
so you're going to go from small little
unicellular creatures then to
multicellular creatures then to
creatures with different layers and body
layers and then eventually you're going
to get to where we are today
that makes according to that logic sense
so originally there was one cell then a
little ball of cells that little ball of
cells developed an indentation that
indentation eventually became your gut
it became a tube through you then they
developed The Cordial backbone and then
you have the vertebrates and this takes
millions and millions of years until you
have the first little creature about the
size of a Minnie Mouse
and then maybe it had pink shoes I don't
know
and then it developed bigger and bigger
until eventually you get the big animals
right
so why does it
why is it so that instead of
seeing a sequence in the old Fossil Beds
of only small creatures
to very large creatures lately why not
why do we see basically every their
everything there from the beginning yeah
and everything much bigger than it is
today and then it gets progressively
smaller yeah yeah it's the reverse of
what you must expect still it's it's not
Evolution you always say it's Devolution
it's devolution
now there's a web page where an artist
tried to capture this as realistically
according to the science as possible
just to show what the size differences
was
and here is the web page it's
boardpanda.com
and he's got 37 comparisons of the sizes
of prehistoric animal ancestors and
their modern relatives this is an
interview by Rahman yukitel with the
artist and I've just taken some of the
pictures from his web page for
educational purposes just to show what
science actually says about the size
differences I've only taken some I'm not
taking 37. so let's have a look at some
of them
there is a size comparison of the sloth
now there is the prehistoric giant sloth
and that's the size of the current
sloth yeah is there a size difference a
little bit
there's a size difference right
now obviously when you find a fossil
of a giant sloth that is this big then
you say to yourself that was a different
world yeah what's going on there now you
can take anything you take the insect
world
dragonflies had two foot Wings yeah they
come roaring here they wouldn't fit
between us right I don't want to know
spiders cockroaches were this big don't
even tell me about a spider because the
spiders and those things those would
think you are a tasty morsel
all right this friend of mine has
arachnophobia
[Laughter]
all right so that was the size
difference now what's interesting
you would imagine that creatures like
this of this huge size
sound very prehistoric yeah you know it
belongs to the dinosaur age I'm not even
going to show the dinosaurs but this is
dinosaur age and it's millions and
millions and millions and millions of
years ago do you know Martin that they
found skins intact skins of giant sloths
in caves in South America
that was still intact yeah no some
Farmers actually put them up at their
Dwelling Places but how many millions of
years can these things be in the past if
the Skins are still intact no it's
impossible if you even if it's frozen
because according to their narrative it
couldn't have stayed the same for
millions of years yeah it always would
have changed all right let's have a look
at the wombat
this is the fossil one the prehistoric
one the size that it would be compared
to the present wombat
is that Evolution or devolutions
complete Devolution isn't that
deterioration or progress in size
definitely not progress in size so it's
regression it's regression I mean all
right now if you just look at that this
is just the Animal Kingdom so when the
Bible speaks about
Giants yeah and explains how big their
beds were
then people say yeah Ferris fairy tale
and then they depict the Giants as a
you know androthal is stupid doesn't
know yes and so imagine
um Abraham
he was almost a stature of angels still
till the time of Abraham but you know
Martin this is fascinating so maybe the
story in the Bible is not so ridiculous
right
let's have a look at another one here's
the lion
and uh this is the prehistoric one
it's double the size of the present one
yeah double the size
now if you saw a lion that size it would
freak you out right yeah
or look at the orangutan
yeah there's the size of the prehistoric
one if you saw one like that wouldn't
you say it was a giant yes you will
compared to a fully grown present one
yeah you would say it was a giant
so not only the animal world has
deteriorated
but humankind has deteriorated right
definitely
I just want to ask a question
um earlier you said you're not going to
mention anything on dinosaurs or so I
just want to know dinosaurs what type of
animal that they classifiers they were
reptiles okay and that mammal-like uh
reptile okay when you take a skull of a
mammal and you compare it to the skull
of a reptile the foramen on the side the
holes on the side to make it simple
are different okay now the mammal-like
reptiles had features of both
and today you don't have that you only
have the one and you only have the other
and they were they were huge creatures
comparable to dinosaurs but also had
features comparable probably to mammals
so they were they were a mixture
now I didn't really want to go into that
but when when the spirit of Prophecy for
example talks about confused species yes
yes then I could imagine that that was a
form of amalgamation
so maybe there was technology in those
days that weed cannot even comprehend or
are just approaching to yes where we can
actually amalgamate various creatures we
were seeing that happen now correct it's
that experimentation is ongoing in the
world
but let's get back to our size
differences just a few interesting ones
here's a modern capybara which is a
rodent creature about this size modern
and there is the counterpart in the
fossil record it looks like the size of
a hippo yes
I mean did you say huge decline in size
or the armadillo look at that I mean
it's a massive difference I know what I
was just thinking
obviously the vegetation also had to be
larger everything was larger the trees
were larger that's why we have these
massive coal Fields that's why we have
all of the resources that we have today
we call them fossil fuels
so there must have been gigantic forests
and huge huge quantities of animals you
know just not the other day here in
South Africa we had a massive red tide
and thousands upon thousands of tons of
crayfish yeah washed up on the shore
thousands upon thousands of tons in a
fallen world
imagine an unfallen world now if the the
oceans were not as deep then as they are
now then they would have been productive
across their entire area and much of the
water that we have today was actually
under the mantle Subterranean water
so all of that has changed that means
that the entire area was productive yeah
and they would have been a vast amount
of organic material
an inexhaustible amount almost which we
today drive around with as fossil fuels
that's it and that's why they get all
these huge oil fields and all of this in
in the bottom of the sea exactly but
that's a different topic
so these are very interesting
comparisons here's a modern horse
compared to a fossil horse
there is a modern great white shark
compared to a fossil one I mean the
large great white
would just be a toothpick for this guy
right a Megalodon yes
so that tells you that something has
drastically changed modern is this in
line
with the evolutionary theory or is this
in line with scripture 100 with
scripture evolution
we actually would have had bigger ones
now yes it would have gone the other way
around
or let's take the Bison everybody's so
impressed with the size of a bison this
day
is a toy compared to this fellow
the prehistoric bison
or the crocodile
the size difference this is a fully
grown crocodile today and that's what
you find in the fossil record
now one feature about reptiles modern
is that they continue to grow throughout
their life cycle mammals seem to have a
cut-off point they grow to a size and
then they stay there
but not reptiles they continue growing
sure so if you take a dinosaur
and it comes out of an egg this size
that means when it's hatched out of its
egg it's the size of a chicken yeah
now that dinosaur from the size of a
chicken over years will grow and it
won't stop growing
so if you take these crocodiles that you
had in the fossil record why are they so
large well firstly they had a perfect
environment yes they probably had
different diet as well it was probably
plant-based
there's a lecture on that creation to
Restoration people can have a look at
that one perhaps you can put a link and
put a link in it
now they would just continue to grow
and if the the situation was idyllic
then the size would have been of course
drastically
larger than today and the dinosaur would
keep on growing until it didn't fit into
this room anymore
so if you had to take them into the ark
would you take a fully grown one or
would you take a juvenile yeah a
juvenile no problem
no problem so that makes it also the
more
um understandable that the arc
narrative
is true well there are many web pages
that talk about the ark and how many
animals went into it the web paid
answers and Genesis has some very good
things in there go and have check it out
and see for yourself well
Evolution says the dinosaur has changed
into a bird how much truth is in that
then well that is a very fascinating
debate
now it's based on some fossil records
where you have imprints of so-called
feathers
but many of the top scientists I mean
like the curators of the Smithsonian
Institute for example
will ridicule that and say there's
absolutely no evidence
that birds evolve from Dinosaurs the
entire structure is different the the
tale for example of a dinosaur is a
massive structure which is completely
gone in a bird the the bone structure is
totally different because the bone
structure of a bird is lightweight and
has cavities in it and is superbly
strong although very light yeah
the entire physiology is different
reptiles have sac-like lungs like we
have
whereas birds have through flow lungs
and bird lung is designed to absorb
oxygen on the way in and on the way out
and there's a counter current exchange
between the blood and the airflow and
that is why birds can fly at such
tremendously high altitudes you'll be
with a gas bottle on top of Mount
Everest huffing and puffing and the
geese will go quack quack quack quack
over the top of you
and you'll wonder how do they do that
yeah because of their efficient system
so the entire physiology is different
the diet Anatomy is different the entire
structure of the foot is different and
how the one could ever have evolved out
of the other is highly highly unlikely
okay so but there are questions people
have did the dinosaurs then
how when did they live well whether are
they actually extinct there are
mythologies
of humans
cohabiting with Dinosaurs
if you take the Ikea stones for example
there are drawings on the Ikea stones
from from South America where you have
humans and dinosaurs together
there are stories in the African jungles
of dinosaurs
and if you show some of these people the
indigenous people drawings
for example in Africa of a bear they
don't know it yeah
but you show them a store a picture of a
dinosaur they do know it
so were they on the ark what are all the
myths of dragons and if you read some of
these myths some of them were purely
historical accounts of what happened and
they describe dinosaurs
so the dinosaurs probably
existed and the relics of them might
still exist today
in some areas largely they were probably
wiped out
through hunting
for example if you take the lion
you know if you if you dig up the
Assyrian reliefs yeah you find pictures
of lion hunting and people say there
were no Lions here because there were no
Lions there today okay I understand why
not because they've become extinct
through hunting well if you can take the
Rhino
it was the the black rhino in Africa was
very close to extinction yes so in a
hundred years from today you would have
looked back at a fossil of that and
probably put it a few million years back
correct all right so we've looked at the
first two questions the reverse sequence
and ask ourselves is this in line with
with creation or is this in line with
Evolution let's have a look at some
other questions
question number three
natural selection works by eliminating
the weaker variance
so how does a mechanism
that works by subtraction create more
diversity
that is a very loaded question I
understand because if you have
two
to choose from
and you subject them to environmental
pressure
and the one is fitter than the other one
to fit into that particular
environmental circumstance
then the one survives and the other one
goes extinct that's subtraction you
started with two you end with one
so how does a mechanism that works by
subtraction
Works through multiplication exactly so
you would have to duplicate this in a
thousands of areas but life just doesn't
work like that if a chance happened to
evolve over here
then you would have to postulate that a
chance happened in thousands of places
so that you could still have diversity
so that's an interesting point you're
working with a mechanism of subtraction
to create an increase which is not the
most logical thing to do but we'll come
back to that a little later
another question that arises is why do
the great filer
of the biome all appear simultaneously
in the fossil record in the oldest
fossil records namely in the Cambrian
explosion
when they are supposed to have evolved
sequentially
now just think about that
we are told through Evolution that life
evolved
and then over millions of years it
changed
now a phyla is a huge category of
animals okay
and they are only a limited number of
filer on the planet then subsequently
you divide the filer into subcategories
like you belong to the mammals you're a
mammalian
but you belong to the phyla Cordata
which doesn't only include everything
that has a bony back bone like we have a
fish has a bony backbone a reptile
Hazard a frog Hazard that's they're all
fit into the core data but it also
includes many of the marine organisms
that don't actually have a backbone but
just like a rod a Corda in the back of
their
their system so all of these creatures
together whether they are the
vertebrates which is just a sub category
of the chordates so core data is a
massive group called a phylum
another phylum that you would have would
be mollusca
um
the mollusks that includes every snail
that walks on the land
every
slug that is in the sea all the shelled
organisms they're all mollusks it even
includes the squids and the octopus so
tremendous variety within a phylum right
yeah phylum is a huge category of
animals
and then you have the jointed legged
animals those with an exoskeleton rather
than an endoskeleton that would be the
insects that would be the crabs that
would be anything that has jointed legs
Etc so that's another huge category of
animals now surely Martin the revolution
is right
and life started as a single cell and
then evolved into different organisms
and eventually you had a blob of cells
and then structure developed to develop
differences like the mollusks and the
chordates
or the arthropods the jointed legged
animals or any one of those huge
categories of creatures must take
Millions upon Millions upon millions of
years what if I told you
that they were all there from the
beginning yeah would that shock you're
right out of your seat Well it certainly
would shock you right out of your seat
right
now do scientists know this
we'll come to that the answer is yes
so this is a big question how is it
possible if evolution is true
that all the filer appear already in the
oldest fossil bearing rocks together
they're just there all of them yeah so
there's not a if they say for instance
this beer this fossil is 20 million
years old but in that same period is all
these other ones that might even be
dated older 20 million your way okay
yeah the Cambrian is 600 million so yeah
it doesn't make sense then that
everything there has to be a transition
period correct all right the other
question is why do we have to postulate
punctuated equilibrium to explain away
the lack of intermediary of fossils when
gradualism is the only plausible
explanation for The evolutionary fossil
record
now let me explain that in layman's
terms in layman's terms
punctuated equilibrium versus gradualism
now gradualism is basically darvanianism
Darwin postulated that one kind
gradually evolved into another kind over
a long period of time
that is the only plausible way
to explain evolution
slow change through accumulated
mutations of a long periods of time
but in actual fact
this gradualism is not borne out by the
fossil record no because all of the
phyla are there from the beginning
simultaneously okay scratch your head
so how do you explain that
well you come up with a solution
which is called punctuated equilibrium
that means obviously there must have
been time of no change equilibrium yeah
and then bomb punctuated sudden rapid
change so rapid that you can't pick up
the transitions in the fossil record why
would they have to do that because they
cannot explain why everything is there
simultaneously and why there are no
transitions yes why don't they have a
missing link you cannot find that one
correct so knowing that this is a
problem in the fossil record
scientists have come up with punctuated
equilibrium because many many big Banks
correct and Stephen J Gould is the one
who came up with the idea
to explain the lack of intermediary
fossils to explain the fact that they're
all there at the same time so Martin if
they have to postulate something like
punctuated equilibrium are they thereby
admitting that the fossil record doesn't
bear out gradualism definitely they have
to all right now I myself was an
evolutionist yeah
and I was a punctuated equilibrianist
why because you couldn't explain the
other part there was no other choice
if I wanted to remain an evolutionist I
had to become a punctuated equilibrium
okay so dupunctuated like a librarianism
say that again that was fun don't cut
that out please
punctuated equilibriumists
I think I got it you got it okay do they
then believe that humans will also
create like that punctuated suddenly
they were there there but the the
intermediaries they're not there because
they can't find the missing link correct
it's not there so this is the whole
point Martin now I have another question
for you
punctuated equilibrium is there because
everything is in the fossil record
already
what is the innate difference between
punctuated equilibrianism
and creation
but there is no the only thing that's
different is the one has a God and the
other one does I just wanted to say
there's a Creator in the one and the
other one is just by chance correct so
one thing to deny the Creator
I had to be a punctuated equilibrium
It's actually an oxymoron because you
just have to you have to have the same
faith
aha so punctuated equilibrium
has faith in Rapid Evolution so rapid
that everything is there at the same
time
exactly
God created everything modern
there is no room for a Divine foot in
the door you understand the problem
okay so we are in the business of
expounding the Three Angels messages
The Three Angels messages the first
Angel's message is about worship
worship Him who made
is this
a system of worship
definitely oh yes so what are you
worshiping you are worshiping here the
inherent power of nature to produce a
miracle everything is there at the same
time so you've replaced your God you've
replaced God the Creator with Mother
Earth you have replaced her with Mother
Earth or Mother Nature so actual fact
if you are a punctuated equilibriumist
you are a Gaia worshiper you just don't
want to give it that name and that is
the more logic
of the evolution beliefs to have because
you can't explain gradualism
correct because it's not borne out in
the fossil record and Darwin himself
admitted admitted that this is the flaw
in his theory
and in order to circumvent the floor
you have punctuated equilibrium now
that's the way it is
let's go to some other questions if
natural selection works at the level of
the phenotype
and not the level of the G note type
then how did genes mitosis meiosis with
their intricate and highly accurate
mechanisms of Gene transfer evolve
it would have to be by random charts now
that's a mouthful
so I have to unpack it we'll unpack it
with pictures just now but let's just
talk about it that was
definitely one of the questions that I
put on the board
because evolution of necessity
has to work with what is physically
present
uh survival of the fittest
the two that you are comparing the one
that's going to be not so fit and the
one that is fit have to be physically
there exactly that one can't be missing
right so if they are physically there
the obvious question is how did they get
there
are you with me yes we'll unpack it just
now a little bit more
so the phenotype is what is physically
there but you can see so Martin never
had to explain your phenotype I would
now give a description of what you look
like but because I'm naughty I'm not
going to do that because it would have
something to do with my hair
probably
now if you had to give one about me then
you could also you know nitpick but do
it leave it at this all right but the
fact of the matter is I'm taller than
you yeah
all right but now because I'm older I
probably can't run as fast as you can
but in the old days when I was younger
if I were the same age I would probably
be able to run faster than you because
I've got longer legs right that's it so
in an escape situation in the African
bush I would probably outrun you right
so I would be you would be the meal yes
I would have been the survival of the
fittest you will be the fittest and I
would have not okay what determines your
phenotype your jeans aha
your genes determine your phenotype but
the genes are like information yeah that
is transferred into your phenotype but
evolution can do nothing with your
genotype it can only test the
what's that the ability of what's
actually the result there of you can you
run faster than me
that is the question right that but that
you can also just see according to the
phenotype all right so when it comes to
the selective pressure whatever it is
let's call it climate changes the
selective pressure it's now becoming
warmer yes all right and the one
creature is overheating because it has a
heavy fur and the other one has a
shorter fur that's a phenotypic
difference the one that is more likely
to survive the heat wave is the one that
has the shorter fur and can get rid of
the heat easier right okay so that's a
way to deal with it
that's the phenotype the genes how did
they come into existence
natural selection cannot work with
letters and numbers because they're not
producing anything yet
the letters and the numbers had to come
about by chance
so bottom line is
natural selection only works at the
level of the phenotype not the level of
the genotype then how did the genotype
which can only be tested as to its
adequacy once it has produced the
phenotype
how did they come about
or what about the processes to transfer
the genes to the Next Generation
or to multiply the cells which is
mitosis
or the process to take it to the next
Generation which is meiosis
with all their highly intricate
mechanisms
of Gene transfer how did they come into
existence like you said by chance by
chance
so it would have to be by random chance
something just happened to work and
produced a viable phenotype
one gene can never do it to get you into
a viable phenotype takes millions and
millions of genes exactly
all right so we're moving heavily into
the realm of faith when it comes to this
exactly that's what I just wanted to say
this is you have this it's a religion
you have to have faith to believe that
it's by chance correct now number seven
the process of crossing over
during meiosis
that's when genes actually transfer
information
[Music]
but that information must first produce
uh Offspring before it can be tested
natural selection only comes into play
when the thing is actually there we're
now playing with numbers here
so how did that highly sophisticated
mechanism that requires such absolute
precision
how did it come about so how could
natural selection bring this about if it
is only operative at the level of the
phenotype the answer is by chance yeah
now it's becoming a faith and that's
what I said by faith
now when I got to this point in the
discussion
one of those students got up and said so
you're telling me
that this is actually a religion
and then I was
duped into giving up my religion
and this created the Outburst of anger
just a side note did you do you know if
that student ever
got back to Faith
that student who was actually
without me knowing was I never even knew
they existed an Adventist wow
and years later
I received a message
that this person had heard that I was a
lecturer
had changed my opinion on Evolution and
she couldn't believe it
I think she's actually married to a
pastor oh wow so I could apologize to
her for my rudeness wow I think there
was people that in from your testimony
that actually would appreciate this
answer yes well
so the next question I also have is how
can we explain the evolution of two
sexes
with compatible anatomical differences
when only the result of the Union
increased diversity in The Offspring is
subject to selection but not the cause
let me run that by you Martin
in order to have natural selection
to have something to work with there
must be variety yes
now we've seen that natural selection
actually reduces the variety yes so it's
a mechanism that makes less and less so
how are we going to feed its hunger for
variety
are you with me that's it so so
evolutionists have an explanation okay
they say the fact that there is Gene
transfer between a male and a female
produces massive variety
and that variety must then be put into
actual phenotypes little different
offsprings
so if you have children they don't all
look exactly the same there's variety
because there is this exchange of
genetic material
but it doesn't explain where the two
Sexes come from to produce the variety
in the first place neither does it
explain the absolute intricacy of the
mechanism that is required to produce
The Offspring in the two Sexes those two
can produce something that correct
neither does it explain why there is
such an anatomical difference between a
male and a female in order to achieve
this in the first place neither does it
explain how these various cells come
together to produce a variety in The
Offspring by the union of a male and a
female germ cell which now has to mingle
its genetic information then still chop
it up and change it over for the next
generation and then produce a phenotype
that eventually will be subject to
Natural Selection it all had to come
about by chance chance exactly it's
impossible to explain this in any other
way all right and God said he created
the male and female
period that's it now what created the
male and female in the evolutionary
scenario chance uh-huh is that the faith
yeah of course it has to be because you
cannot prove it it's a religion yeah
it's a religion but it is the only thing
that actually explains where the variety
comes from that you need to feed this
hungry beast called natural selection
isn't it sad that this is the narrative
that the whole world is being taught all
right now if you look at that and you
realize that God created the male and
female
I don't want to go there but what does
it do to woke thinking exactly they you
can think what you are exactly but let's
not go there it's not part of this
discussion
there are other problems with the
evolutionary scenario number one you
have to postulate where Mata came from
because you are a physical being
right yeah did I just take it for
granted that everything is there yeah
but didn't I come from a big bang
well we'll talk about that so you have
to postulate the origin of matter where
does it come from it doesn't just stay
with the evolution of one animal kind to
another kind it transcends all the
Sciences
now how many peer review
articles must there be in the world to
cover all of those aspects millions and
they're all postulations
so we're looking for dark matter
because we have to postulate that it's
there
okay
even if you don't find it right
so origin of matter where did it come
from origin of the genetic code
these have to be massive chance
occurrences that just happen to
provide everything that you need
this provides the matter for everything
that is used in physical life this
provides the
genetic variability the the code of the
genetic
the genetic code puts the matter
together to get something that actually
correct it exists and then you also have
to explain something which scientists
are calling irreducible complexity
irreducible complexity means that
whichever you're talking about couldn't
have evolved over time
because the thing is so complex and only
works if everything is put together at
the same time and everything has to be
there in order for it to operate we'll
look at an example just now
so it's irreducibly complex you take one
component Outlook if I take my watch and
I rip out one of the wheels and I throw
it away my watch doesn't work because it
needs that peace but it also needs all
the other pieces that are in the watch
and if I take any one of them out my
watch is not going to work it is
irreducibly complex whatever is in there
has to be means to be in there
so some of the irreducibly complex
things
how did they evolve
it because I cannot create my watch
incrementally I cannot
throw a cog down there
and then another one and another one
until I've thrown all the parts required
for my watch onto the table
how's it going to get together if
there's no designer
right it's exactly all loose and
everywhere you cannot get it the problem
is Martin we cannot afford a designer so
you have to think up something for this
the designer has to go there's no room
for a Divine foot in the door that's
what they say yeah
and they are evolutionists
that believe in irreducible complexity
without believing in a designer
their designer has to be called chance
chance so their faith their God is
chance it's a religion
not to speak about the universal flood
about which the Bible speaks about we
have to look at some of these issues
so this was just the introduction Martin
that's good I'm sure people will be
hungry to see what's coming next
so basically Martin what we're saying is
that in any one of these issues
if you want to remove God out of the
equation
then you are moving into the realm of
Faith that's it there's no other way
there's no other way
and then you have a faith-based religion
which is called science
and
it is in opposition to what the word
says it has to be because it cannot
survive
so if it wants to marry what the word
says with itself call itself theistic
evolution
then you have a mingling of Truth
and supposition which would be error
yeah okay let's look at the origin of
matter and then we'll continue our
discussion in another episode yes
because so we can get the whole picture
exactly that we can fit this puzzle
together okay let's look at the origin
of matter what does the Bible say where
does matter come from he's spoken and
stood fast yeah so the voice of God
by the word
by the word of the Lord were the heavens
and the earth created so he spoke and it
stood fast and it's by that word that
you live not by bread alone correct now
who came up with the idea of a big bang
what's the Jesuits Martin
the Jesuits the Jesuits who called the
Bible particularly this version which is
the King James version they called it
that poisonous ASP that they were to
grab it by the tail like the serpent of
Moses
and get rid of it
well they haven't gotten rid of it you
know but they're trying very hard at the
level of learning against learning which
is universities now let's see how
brilliant scientists come up with an
answer to this well here is a physicist
and his name is Lawrence Krauss he's a
Quantum physicist okay now quantum
physics is actually
very interesting because it mingles
mysticism
with reality okay so it's actually a
religion and science mixed yes because
it doesn't have any other choice because
there are things that are so
inexplicable
that they require a mystical answer and
so they gave themselves a name that
sounds very clever yes so let's look at
an article which he posted in 2010
already and which is the basis
of the origin of everything
how to get something namely the universe
out of nothing
it sounds familiar yes God created
everything out of nothing
quantum physics comes with exactly the
same solution
so when we March backwards along the
arrow of time we reach the point from
which everything began
the point that modern science calls the
Big Bang
Jesuits coined that phrase
scientists have a wonderful grasp
it really sounds very scientific
and I'm sure there are thousands of
peer-reviewed papers to substantiate
what he is saying
scientists have a wonderful grasp on
what happened a billionth of a billionth
of a second after the big bang
this of course only begs the question
what came before the Big Bang
but we know we have a wonderful grasp of
what happened a billionth of a billionth
of a second
after the big bang
but before that we have to have faith
let's see what he says
physicist Lawrence Krauss demonstrate
that the answer is nothing okay
and that under our current understanding
of physics and contrary to traditional
logic it is not just probable
that we get something out of nothing it
is absolutely inevitable
this is the standing of modern science
everything was created from
nothing
and we have a wonderful understanding of
what happened a billionth of a billionth
of a second
when nothing exploded
namely everything
that you see today we study it and we
explain it and we use the evolutionary
theory like we discussed it here and we
know what it looks like now but what did
it exist consist of before that nothing
nothing yeah
may I ask you
as someone not in this field
you as educated in books and auditing
and bookkeeping and things like that if
you had to do some bookkeeping of what
happened the billionth of a billionth of
a second after nothing exploded what
would you conclude would be there when
nothing exploded
nothing nothing all right exactly but in
actual fact we've got everything so your
bookkeeping only starts once everything
has exploded this won't balance right so
nothing exploded
and created everything
is that faith
of course how much Faith do you need to
believe that it's absolutely inevitable
that nothing exploded and created
everything you have to have 100 faith in
it all right what does it exclude
God God yeah we come back to that point
every single time
so Martin if we look at the universe and
we look at the vast dust clouds they all
came from nothing
[Music]
and these vast clouds of nothing
expanded into everything
and if you had an explosion everything
would go out centrally from a central
point
sure and so they say the universe is
expanding because it exploded yeah then
at some stage it will come back upon
itself because of what they call gravity
and it will implode correct now here I
have a major problem
the forces of gravity
will never ever be able to gather
everything back again upon itself let
alone let it collapse
and so how do you get things like stars
and in the if nothing exploded well then
basically you had nothing
but in actual fact they don't actually
have nothing they have protons which is
the smallest particle in the hydrogen
atom right yeah they had protons they
don't say where the proteins come from
if you break them up they consist of
quarks yeah and there are three quarks
now they can only exist in threes
if you remove one
then the other two will suddenly have
another one yeah where did that come
from out of nothing and the one that was
one would have another two attached to
it
because it can never exist as one it has
to exist as three
so everything has to suddenly come into
existence out of nothing because it is
required to be something
well that makes me think of something
else this that they can only they can
only be three the whole time yes but uh
don't don't go there Martin are you
going to create controversy a very
controversial fellow you know man
but the whole idea
is that everything then coalesced into
Stars
they realize that you cannot get them to
coalesce into stars because if I pop a
balloon yeah and the gas dissipates what
is the probability that I can get the
gas back into the balloon zero right but
they have to postulate that not only
that it has to collapse upon itself and
create a star then they have to have
nuclear fusion within the star so that
out of just
gas and protons they can push them all
together and make all the other atoms
that are needed to make life
but then they have to get into the
environment so that star will have to
explode in a supernova
to create all the other material that is
necessary for life and once enough of
that has accumulated then that coalesces
then eventually you get planet Earth
and then you have the right conditions
and you can get life to evolve on planet
Earth because you have to explain from
nothing exploding and creating
everything how you get from nothing to
you yeah
is it the religion I think it's a
I think it's a hard religion but it's a
religion yeah so this is the theory of
the Big Bang well opposed to that
now you just have the matter yeah you
still have to transform the matter
which came from nothing
into something
and then you have to start the
evolutionary process so that you can
create the philosopher who thinks about
how nothing exploded and created
everything
and the whole world is full of
philosophers exactly and they call it
science that's it and the whole world is
being toured this
I think if I remember correctly it was a
comment of somebody that mentioned there
was a big bang but it was when God spoke
you are right God spoke and there was a
big bang
and everything was there it was formless
and void
and then God ordered it
just the fact that God ordered it is
contrary to the laws of thermodynamics
because thermodynamics says that
everything deteriorates from a system of
order to disorder that is a constant law
and evolution has to violate that law
So within that law they create pockets
of order
in order to circumvent the law modern
this is a very deep subject and we can
carry on discussing this forever and
ever
I think we should take a short break
here
and then come back and just look at the
other side of the story what do you say
I think that will be awesome I think
there's a lot that people can go and do
some self-study on after this episode
and we'll continue it again in the next
one let's continue in the next one let's
pray
Heavenly Father
we are faced with different religious
systems in the world
and science
particularly certain aspects of science
qualifies religion
and we have to choose this day
whom we will serve
help us to make right choices by not
just looking at science
but looking at all the other evidence as
well is my prayer in Jesus name
amen amen
[Music]
thank you